We all love images on the web.
Images can be beautiful,
fun, and informative.
Now the web started life as a,
a text only medium.
Check out these early versions
of well known websites.
Thefacebook.com looks pretty cool, huh?
But the ability to embed
images was the innovation that
really made the web take off.
And now we have an incredible
wealth of images on the web.
Here's one of millions of pictures
from the Google Art Project.
You can probably get
closer to the picture here
than you can in the actual museum.
Now, given the huge and increasing
variety of devices and contexts for
consuming web content now, we need to
think again about how we use images.
I'm Sam Dutton,
a developer advocate at Google.
>> And I'm Cameron Pittman,
a course developer at Udacity.
>> And we'll be teaching you how
to use images responsively so
they work really well across a variety
of devices, display sizes, and
connectivity scenarios.
>> Throughout this class you'll
be building a webpage design for
a blog site that uses
several kinds of images.
>> And by the end you'll be
confident that you can incorporate
images responsively in your own work.
>> Let's get started.
>> Yeah, let's do it.